most of us would probably say we'd like
to be more intelligent that it'd be cool
to be a genius but the problem is that
most of us would probably also struggle
to define exactly what intelligence or
genius are so defining intelligence as a
high IQ is a somewhat arbitrary and
imperfect measure you can have a low IQ
and still be very intelligent in a lot
of different ways and that's really the
problem it seems that there's lots of
different forms of intelligence so this
is a modular view of intelligence that's
saying that you have lots of different
kinds of intelligence lots of different
brain areas responsible for lots of
different processes in the brain and you
can be good at one and not so good at
another one of the most famous theories
that goes down this route is Gardiner's
theory of multiple intelligences so how
a garden was a psychologist who said
that intelligence should be broken down
into several different categories and he
described these as musical rhythmic
visual spatial verbal linguistic logical
mathematical bodily kinesthetic
interpersonal intrapersonal and
naturalistic so basically he's saying
that you could be great in your
linguistic intelligence but not so great
in your mathematical intelligence and
indeed we all know people like this who
might not be so good at math that
doesn't mean that they're dumb because
they're great at speaking they're witty
they're well-read etc later on garden
would also go on to add moralistic
intelligence and existential
intelligence to that list so all there
is some biological basis for this
argument I find the gardener's examples
in particular are somewhat arbitrary and
random and I can't really understand why
they're given as much credit as they are
I mean why do we have an interpersonal
and interpersonal as separate categories
of intelligence when surely there's a
huge overlap between those skills
likewise for linguistic well that's not
to say that a module of you is useless
and there is quite a lot of research
backing up this approach to begin with
we know that there's a distinction
between fluid intelligence and
crystallized intelligence so fluid
intelligence is your dynamic
intelligence your ability to perform
math answer reasoning problems and then
crystallized intelligence is your
knowledge the amount of information have
stores these are both useful but they're
completely different skills normally
when we talk about intelligence we're
talking about fluid intelligence and
that's what IQ scores Raptors
and more so than crystallised
intelligence and what also back to step
of course is the simple fact that the
brain is generally structured in that
way it's divided into different areas
different clusters of neurons which
perform specific activities and
functions so you have your Broca's area
for language you have the intraparietal
sulcus for math you have your motor
cortex for movement all these different
things and so it does make sense that
one area could be bigger than the other
or more used than the other because the
brain is organized in that way and in
keeping with this is the fact that brain
damage to specific areas can result in
very domain-specific
deficits in terms of cognitive
performance so one example of this is
prosopagnosia and this is a condition
where people have damage to either the
occipital face area or the fusiform face
area in the brain and this results in
their inability to recognize faces so
they're perfectly intelligent they can
see just fine but they can't recognize
their friends and they can't tell people
apart and that shows how in theory you
can be completely fine very bright but
if one brain area is poor then you're
gonna have poor performance in that one
specific domain but more interesting
still is there is some negative
correlation between these different
types of intelligence so if you're
really good at one you actually likely
to be slightly worse at the other so if
you're really good at maths then
statistically and want it to be slightly
worse at language that's not always the
case but it's often the case this is why
we get late speakers becoming engineers
and mathematicians why a lot of people
with dyslexia go on to do maths and
engineering Einstein was a late speaker
it can also explain the nutty professor
kind of type someone who's great at
philosophy and science and maths always
in their own head coming up with new
ideas at the same time they're not so
good at remembering where their keys
whether to have great interpersonal
skills and from a biological perspective
it seems that these types of people have
fewer d2 dopamine receptors in the
thalamus so we can actually demonstrate
this by looking at their brains what's
even more interesting in this regard is
autistic savant ISM so a autistic savant
is someone who has autism that starts
poor interpersonal skills but they are
extremely gifted in a particular area
and now not all of all autistic people
have savant ISM us definitely a
misconception and myth
most don't but there are a few
exceptions people who can perfectly draw
a city scene after just seeing it once
or people who are capable of doing
incredible math telling you what day you
were born on but then they struggle with
social interaction and in one study it
was found that by using transcranial
magnetic stimulation to suppress the
language and interpersonal areas of a
healthy regular brain it was possible to
improve abilities in that so to induce
autistic savant ISM seemingly in regular
participants by stimulating their brains
through their Scouts with magnetism so
by shutting down one brain area
temporarily another area gets a
temporary boost which is fascinating and
has a ton of transhuman and nootropic
potential and interesting this also kind
of throws out some of the explanations
as to why this might be the case why we
might have better abilities in some
areas than others because obviously you
would say that if someone's bad at math
then they're going to spend more time
learning and focusing on English if
someone's greater art they're going to
do that more and they might neglect
other aspects of their life so of course
you're going to likely have people who
have specific skills in one modality
rather than jack-of-all-trades on the
whole but by saying that when you
suppress one brain area another
instantly improves in performance you're
kind of also saying there's a kind of
resource management thing going on here
where where maybe one's interfering with
the other or one's stealing energy from
the other if you remove it then the
other one gets better and of course we
all know that blind people generally
have better senses the brain has a whole
history of compensating for deficits in
different areas and this community be
achieved in the long-term right brain
plasticity there's all sorts of reasons
why this might be the case but in short
suppressing ability in one cognitive
faculty might improve your ability in
another but this might not seem like a
very satisfactory answer because we all
know people in life who've just seemed
generally brainy like they have great
overall intelligence they're great at
speaking they're great at maths they're
witty in conversation they're always
immaculately presented charming and
frustrating then we've got other people
who might be better in one area than
another we have people who were just
lost causes really so why is it that if
intelligence is all down to categories
and
have one person being overall better at
everything why is it that we think of
some people as intelligent and other
people as not so intelligent well this
could come down to global brain
connectivity which is the amount of
connectivity between the different brain
areas and I said early that Einstein was
someone who seemed to have a very
specialized brain he was a late speaker
he's very good at maths and visual
spatial reasoning and physics but
actually he also had a very thick corpus
callosum which is a bundle of neurons
that connect the left and right
hemispheres of the brain and allows
crosstalk between them and when we think
of someone who's very skilled at
something we think of someone who's able
to accomplish a skill quickly
efficiently and with confidence and this
comes down to rote learning which
develops the plasticity in the area
builds the neural connections so you
have these new pathways for specific
activities and you don't even have to
think about it your fingers just do the
playing on the keyboard or you just
quickly answer that maths question but
we think of genius
more in terms of creativity in terms of
shifting paradigms coming up with new
ideas and this comes down to our ability
to take two separate ideas and combine
them into a unique new idea a unique new
solution they say that there's no such
thing as creativity creativity is the
combination of two existent ideas so if
you have more global brain connectivity
between different brain regions you can
bring in your maths reasoning and your
visual spatial reasoning and your
linguistic skill in the interpersonal
knowledge all into this one cohesive
thought or idea and that's more likely
to result in something that we would
consider genius than just having a very
developed brain area through rote
practice in one particular skill and we
tend to use our brain areas in this way
cohesively altogether we don't you never
just do maths in the real world dear
you're you're constantly predicting
what's going to happen you're
remembering things you're speaking to
people you're moving through space all
at once we have to use everything all
together and bring all this information
in to a cohesive whole and back in this
theory up are plenty of studies that do
show that global brain connectivity is
correlated with high IQ scores also
correlated like you is just gray matter
the weight of your brain the amount of
neurons in your brain the more neurons
you have the more they're connected the
smarter you seem to be the heavy
brain the smarter you seem to be so why
is it that some people are smarter than
others how did they get that way can you
get that way well if we look at it like
this you have all these different brain
areas each one can be better or worse
depending on the amount of size it has
the amount of neural matter in it then
you have the amount of connectivity
between those brain areas and then you
have the amount of weight that all of
this adds up to
well that's brain plasticity it's the
ability of the brain to grow and adapt
to change to form new neural connections
to birth new neurons so that more
plastic your brain is the more it's able
to grow and adapt to its environment the
more intelligent you'll become given the
training given the opportunity giving
the stimulus so it really comes down to
plasticity plus opportunity so if you're
innately highly plastic because you have
the right neural chemical combination
and then you're put through a great
education system or you're just someone
who's very interested yourself and you
go out there and you challenge yourself
and learn new things then your brain
will be highly plastic it'll grow
you'll learn lots of things you'll use
all your different brain areas you'll
use them together and your brain won't
end up thick and big as you develop and
you'll be more intelligent as a result
higher general plasticity will have
greater development in specific brain
areas that we think of as important for
intelligence and they'll also have
greater connectivity between those areas
just because they'll form new
connections more easily and overall the
density of their brain will be greatest
that explains why you'll have these
people who will seem to be great at
everything and also great at coming up
with new insights and ideas by combining
different types of intelligence across
their entire brain so these people we
think of as just super smart are
probably actually super plastic Stan Lee
clearly knew this in the 60s which is
why he gave us mr. fantastic so our
brains are most highly plastic of course
in empathy as we're developing as we're
growing and that's why if you give a
child all the right nutrition the right
sleep the right exercise and then you
give them the right education and
stimulation they'll grow up to be highly
intelligent adults fortunately there are
lots of ways we can increase plasticity
in adulthood so it's not too late for
you it's something I talk about a lot on
this channel and on the website I will
do a video dedicated soon to increasing
plasticity but just some key tips
exercise more sleep more and most
importantly learn expose yourself to new
because the brain reacts to the
opportunity to learn by becoming better
at learning use it or lose it if you
want to become highly plastic then seek
out new opportunities new experiences
and your brain will become more awash
with dopamine and BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor the bottom line is
that to me at least intelligence is
adaptability hope you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like please comment down
below the channel is gaining a lot of
traction lately and it's all thanks to
you guys have been loving the
conversations we're having down below
and yeah I really appreciate it of
course subscribe if you wanna see more
like this and hit the bell button if you
want to get notified of each new video
lots of videos coming up and future on
all the usual stuff brain training
bodybuilding Fitness performance
technology productivity so if that
sounds good then stay tuned and I'll see
you next time thanks for watching and
bye for now